[Music]
[ __ ]
we're docs drop f-bombs in the beginning
oh
we're docks wait am i now i'll do was
that first 15 seconds
let's go with no
oh we got to start this we got to
restart the stream wait really you can't
say f-bomb in the first 15 seconds of
the video or it goes mature rated
no
wait for real how long is the intro uh
ian was that 15 seconds
oh
[Applause]
okay was it really 20 seconds though
okay all right welcome back it's on yo
we got that comp we were doxxed but it's
an undisclosed location in arizona what
the hell dude i mean they just we just
got we
they they got all the we have all those
turrets what good are they doing if they
can you could just like walk in and take
you know take all that footage with like
a dslr
oh it's actually that was government
drone footage that uh they foyered it's
messed up
god damn it welcome back hassan has been
traveling the world
it's true um you've been in uh
europe
what's up you guys went to twitchcon in
like what england or something in
amsterdam and pushkarn eu was uh in
amsterdam this year last time i uh last
time i had it it was in 2019 in berlin
um you know i i really enjoyed it i also
wanted to relaunch my my podcast with
will uh that we do called fear and
maulding uh so i wanted to relaunch it
in like a cool way
uh we're rebranding it and we're calling
it fear and
and then it's going to be like every
episode is going to be like this is
called fear and yeah which is a weird
name right oh yes i like that though
okay because like i think i think weird
names like that
are cool because uh it's it's a really
easy way to penetrate and like have once
you get to a certain level of brand
recognition that weird naming convention
will only forever be associated with you
so i think that it's like it's a pretty
solid way to do it at first it's like
weird you're like for your end that's
weird but then it becomes like marketing
in and of itself basically okay all
right high level stuff here from the sun
it's basically h3 is kind of that like
what the hell is h3 what the hell is h38
man
but now it's forever associated with us
you know i try to explain it but people
just don't want to [ __ ] listen
yeah um
welcome back you know you missed so much
uh check your text messages because how
we or how he doesn't know about the
howie mandel prolapse tiktok i don't
even know if i want to look at this he
sent me an attached job he sent me an
attachment video on okay everyone on
tick tock saw you have to
what do we do about it oh
[Laughter]
that's like i've never been physically
assaulted by by footage dude howie
mandel just dropped that on tick tock
bro and it was up for like
a whole day
three million views and everyone's like
yo howie what the [ __ ] brother
bro good [ __ ] huh that's
i i i don't know what to say to that
well did you listen he goes uh is this
my friend neil bent over and this
happened
wait is he joking or is that actually
like did he just blast neal off like no
no no he's just doing a gag okay a
really good gag from wait isn't this the
guy who like yes sure doesn't like uh
you know bad words and stuff yes sir ow
but he just posted
he just posted like a like a like a
pink rose on the map yeah that's what's
so funny about it because that's like
some e-fuck [ __ ] like that is literally
that's that's you know that's stuff that
you have to search for
yeah yeah yeah no i don't know how he
got it i tried to i really wanted him to
come on the show and explain it he told
me we're we're dogs we text yeah y'all
boys yeah we're boys and i says howie
what's going on bro you got to come talk
about the uh
stock
and he says i'm laying low on the
prolapse so
like you blast off one time you can't
you know he he just dipped his toes in
there and he's like no more no further
comments on this issue yeah i think he
realized i don't know
his clean radar is way off man
but you know what
though it's like when republicans would
be like you know republicans will be
like let's uh let's push for the murder
homosexuals bill and then they're like
how dare you say hell it's he double
hockey stick yeah it's like take the
lord's name in vain yeah it's like death
to all pregnant women yeah it makes no
sense
like your your whole world view is
distorted all right well we're back in
the bunker thank you by the way our
incredible new introduction by preston
wow shout outs out to preston wow wow
wow you're a real one also shout outs to
stamps.com is there in a more american
institution than that no we love them
shout us out to stamps.com and preston
we've got so much to talk about um we've
been gone for a minute it's almost hard
to decide where to begin i know
jeez
um
what have we missed i mean well joe
biden got coronavirus so that that
happened earlier this morning that's
fresh luckily he's young he's gonna he's
gonna he's gonna make it i was when dan
told me uh
joe had coveted i just said rip he said
no that was me
i was you yeah what's up or maybe you
said the same to both me and dan yeah it
was you it was you
i don't know he's gonna die i'll be
honest i mean i no i hope the fbi's not
showing up for this one well we're not
gonna do it right we're not gonna no
obviously i'm not saying we're gonna
i'm saying that like
that's how it always happens like this
is how it always happens like you you
look at trump who's like
not in the best shape right coke lives
on yeah lives on diet coke and like
hamburgers cheeseburgers right his
entire
his blood is just transfused
right and he's still kicking like
nothing he
he is i'll tell you say what what you
want about trump
that man is somehow
the paragon of health and
and uh
grace he's grace at old age the man is
sharp as a tap compared to joey boy well
i mean look it's like
it's like henry kissinger and dick
cheney like dick cheney
dick cheney should have died a long time
ago you know what i mean like he has
like a fake heart in there i think they
put like an ox heart in there or
something i don't know what the [ __ ]
going on
like
my man is alive like he
he's got a fat hog too i don't know if
you knew that yeah it's unrelated yeah
he's calling big dick cheney in college
there's photos there's photos no there's
not so he he was a nude uh model in
college for like artists pull that up
like you know how like artists would
draw yeah yeah yeah he used to do that
yeah dick cheney there's yeah he's
calling big danny dick there's a photo
there's you can see you can see his
piece he's like it's like a child's
thermos hi i'm like
yeah and flaccid too i mean he's he's
got a fat one okay all right let me know
there is no justice on this channel nude
model
well just look up dick cheney
dick cheney's big old fat cop i mean
yeah if you look up dick cheney's dick
you'll
there's like one where he's sitting
and you know
dick cheney big penis okay that's a good
search let's cut to the chase dan don't
[ __ ] around so the reason why i'm
mentioning that though is because like
uh apparently that's part of the reason
why he had to get a [ __ ] heart
transplant because like my man every
time he gets a boner is just like
the entire blood is like sucked out of
his whole body it goes directly to his
whopping 13-incher dude that is a hog
yeah no he's got
can i show this well don't put it on a
screen ian obviously no no but you get
outline it's outline it's like uh put
that up you can put that up it's like a
it's like a don draper outline you know
what i mean it's not like or john hamm
just don't oh my goodness right is that
real and he's talking to the pope with
that thing no bro this is just like a
milkman or something like that that was
the pub that's not the pope yeah they
named it just put that up bro he's not
even he's flaccid brother that's a
flashlight just say we should show it
don't zoom on it okay i'm not zooming
out you can't zoom on it i'm not zooming
on show the photo of happy old days i
mean this was in a newspaper like what
do you mean put it up it's happy old
dick jamie you can see the crinkles on
that paper to the uh milkman by the way
and we wonder where that milk came from
is it from the cow or from dick cheney
so yeah big dick cheney she's got a fat
one
uh look at that no wonder he's so
[ __ ] happy yeah he's like he's
probably he's probably thinking about
like dead arab children or something
that's why he's smiling so so bright
they named him dick for a reason yeah
yeah looks like he's not wearing
underwear too like he's kind of just
letting it all he's kind of flaunting i
think he's probably got like no you know
what it is i think he's probably got
like old man underwear it's like
you know what i mean it's like boxers
like no no no briefs no tighty whities
no no no like one where they like it
just lets your nuts hang you know what i
mean it just lets your [ __ ] hang like
that
um so it's not really doing any there's
no protective coverage there well also
if you have a hog that big why would you
want to wear underwear yeah you know you
want to yeah you want to strut it you
want to showcase it yeah so yeah you
know that's that's big dick cheney uh
the reason why i was mentioning that
though is because you know he's still
every time he gets a boner gets a heart
attack so he had to get a new heart
right and uh not enough blood pressure
to support
his body and his [ __ ] yeah exactly but
let's move on listen we've got uh joe
biden is diana kovid
we have um
jordan peterson
transmoral panic we've got the supreme
court um
doing everything wrong basically from
overturning roe i don't even think we
talked about that
we live in a society
uh two
yeah that's about it
basically but basically um
what do you think bro what's going on
out there where should we begin let's
look at i was gonna start out with some
light stuff you know what i mean talking
about eu i was in i was in the uk i was
in amsterdam
um we did the you know we we just kind
of did like an impromptu trip out there
and at first when i went to london i was
like
man this is what a city is supposed to
be like you know you got working public
transit
it's like relatively walkable and stuff
um
and boy was i wrong i mean after i went
to amsterdam i was like holy [ __ ] the uk
sucks
i mean amsterdam i get why so many
people stand amsterdam it's not the
drugs and prostitution all that stuff
it's just straight up like lanes it's
incredible downtown downtown amsterdam
no cars allowed oh it's just walking and
biking
uh it's it's wonderful it's beautiful
it's uh well preserved
you know what i mean like here's a
country that
uh here's a country that accumulated a
profound amount of wealth off of slavery
and you know the spice trade and whatnot
and then actually then you know
made sure to to
uh at the very least build like
beautiful cities and whatnot and rather
than in america
you know they they did the slavery thing
and they were like yeah we're still
gonna treat the domestic uh population
like [ __ ]
many many years later so they they took
the slave money
and they they did a good they did good
work with their slave money yeah which
doesn't mean that it's like morally
justifiable obviously it's still well if
you got it flaunt it in the case of dick
cheney and then you know slave money
yeah so
it's it's beautiful public transit works
so well it was just it was such a treat
to be able to get on a metro and then a
tram and
and you walk around at like
3 a.m
and you don't feel unsafe ever you know
what i mean you're the red light
district dudes are just coming up to you
trying to give you drugs they're
literally so pushy with like the the
drug sales apparently because it's fake
it's not real drugs they're just like
crushing aspirin oh so it's like not
illegal
but they're doing it like under cameras
they're doing in front of cops and [ __ ]
they're like cocaine come get cocaine
bro i'm like no i don't want to gnarly
because you expected amsterdam it would
be real drugs yeah well if you want real
drugs just go to the coffee shops right
but they sell like cocaine and mdma and
[ __ ] at the coffee no they sell like
mushrooms and wheat mushrooms weed yeah
yeah hash that sort of did you get into
mushrooms or anything no fun
unfortunately i was working the entire
time i just met like
thousands of fans uh doing twitch kaniu
and stuff that was really great mm-hmm
but
uh but ultimately it was it was a
beautiful experience and i look forward
to going back we did the red light
district we went in uh on a boat
illegally um
no probably uh i did not experience
i've been to brothels yeah i've talked
about this before yeah and obviously i'm
very pro sex worker i dated a sex worker
uh a bag in the day
and for me the red light district was a
little like it was a little icky like at
least with the brothel there's like a
there's like privacy and it's like a
closed-off environment whereas like this
is literally on the street
like and the the sex workers are like
sitting inside of like these little
aquariums basically yeah and they're
just like trying to get you to come in
to that little aquarium
and you know you haggle and then they
close the curtain they [ __ ] you and then
sex they clean up yeah yeah
i went to a similar thing when i was in
germany when i was like 18. i was a
virgin at the time i probably wasn't i'd
even get to like third base by that time
and i was like what the [ __ ] i was too
scared to hit him up obviously we were
more just like curious but yeah it was
the same kind of thing where there's
like women in behind
like glass windows yeah on the street
and you can walk through like massive
hotels
full of women trying to get you in there
it's pretty wild it's it's definitely
it's definitely uh it was a weird
experience for me but also i found out
that the the dutch government literally
offers stipends to people with
disabilities to be able to get sex work
like to be able to get sex workers like
higher sex workers what
yeah i wonder if i would be eligible for
one of those coupons
maybe probably not but um but yeah no
it's just like a drastically sick it's a
drastically different culture and it's a
drastically different attitude to have
towards sex work in general they they
consider it to be like compassionate uh
to to do that you know uh you know
whereas in the united states of america
we're like here buy a gun and and shoot
up a school that's what that's the way
we deal with uh that sort of thing here
in america if you want to blow off steam
it's great so clearly who's to say which
one's better i don't know um
you know um what was the price for did
you did you see the menu i'm just
curious what kind of prices it was no i
didn't actually like i didn't actually
uh go in and like uh
like haggle or anything like that but i
think it's like around 150 euros maybe
for like for like an hour or like a
night i think it's just a nut just until
you're done it's like but i don't know i
i got to put it it's probably your time
yeah yeah
i let her have her way a fun 50 euro
tonight
yeah it's a good deal
but it's out but
it's more anyway five percent of the sex
workers uh are men uh there's trans sex
workers as well their color is purple uh
men are blue wait whoa you mean like a
light yeah it depending on the light in
the world in the window yeah
and is there a different light for men
who are
homosexual or they're blue heterosexual
like blue is men i think there's no
light between hetero no i don't think so
homosexual i don't think so but yeah
five percent oh love gloves coming with
the facts you have something like this
or is this just research
yeah i just google it
sweden is like decriminalized right it's
not legal but uh yeah it's not illegal
for the women but it's illegal to buy i
think yeah
it's it's they only prosecute john's
that's that's that's interesting
love says window prostitution prices
range between 50
to 100 euro duration usually lasts 15 to
30 minutes so there you go
that's crazy they're like yo you better
just let's wrap it up like from the
beginning yeah
well you definitely do wrap it up too
that's like
legalization is that like every every
part of the process is like regulated
there's like health standards and stuff
do you need to abide by
i i think it's fin i mean it's utopia
compared to this country in germany for
example like if you want to even finger
a prostitute in a brothel like you have
to put a condom on your finger
it's like that it's like very very
strict understandable for sure you want
to be safe yeah
to protect the sex worker as well yeah
yeah
but um
my dad or let's see my dad would go
through i don't want to bring my dad up
but it's like you go you go you go all
right 100 euro for for 15 minutes so if
i not in two minutes how much money do i
get back
i don't know for lifetime i don't think
it works that way well i'm just saying
bro you can haggle anything i feel like
we wrap this up you cross the finish
line it's done you know what i mean you
can't get it back
you don't know what is your dad refunder
does your dad demand a refund when the
plane like arrives early
[Laughter]
he's just like i don't give him any
ideas
yeah that's that's an interesting
analogy i just mean she was good um but
yeah also i left the country corporate
is on twitch now
uh andrew tate bugatti the bugatti boy
let me ask you a question
because we talked a lot about cobra tate
we've had some in uh
internal dialogue about what's the best
way to represent someone who
is a known sex trafficker
a woman
violent woman abusing
[ __ ] freak
do you what do you think about like xqc
and aiden ross having him on his stream
do you think that
i think there's different or bad i think
there's a difference between like xqc
having that conversation with him versus
uh aiden ross like promoting him yeah
aiden ross just openly like that that it
was not good like that was not good i
don't think you should be platforming a
guy like that but i do think that i
don't have an issue with like debating
him you know okay okay i don't have an
issue with debating like a lot of people
especially
my rule of thumb is like there are
certain people that i will not discuss
there are certain people that i will not
platform at all even to debate because
if they if they don't have like a
massive footprint anyway they then their
their footprint is marginal their impact
is marginal so they're just going to
benefit from even appearing
uh next to you right
but but andrew tate is is gigantic like
his his footprint is huge he's
impossible to [ __ ] avoid it's like
every single thing i've learned about
this man was against my will like i did
not want to know about this person at
all and now i just know so much about
him
and
and i found out why i i
my youtube video probably come out in a
little bit uh i was you know i was
looking into it a little bit i talked to
philly as well
yeah makes some great youtube essays uh
so
he has like a multi-level marketing
scheme yeah i know uh uh the hustlers
university know a lot about hillary yeah
yeah affiliate link back like affiliate
marketing multi-level marketing scheme
for
basically uh you know all the little
short snippets that you get and some
more stuff behind the scenes you know
yeah like it's like herbalife but for me
but you know how he really made his
money before all that yeah sex work um
no he was human traffic
yeah digital pimp yeah i mean but like
you you know that like um
the american embassy raided his compound
because he was holding
women there against their will yeah i
think it was like three american and
like six romanian women or something
yeah bro he's literally a human
trafficker he yeah it's like i just i
don't like that
i don't know my i've explained my
opinion here so i don't think people
need to hear it again but
i'm kind of torn on on if he's worth pla
platforming and debating or not
well like i said it's just because he
there's a certain level of
[ __ ] that's like just
like it's not like funny [ __ ] it's
like actually [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah no no i
think he he is on the [ __ ] [ __ ] side
but even if something is [ __ ] [ __ ]
if there are
like
there was a time and place where i would
have uh like for example debated milo
yiannopoulos right
but now that time has gone by why why
would i have debated miloanopolis in
like 2017. it's because he actually had
mainstream legitimacy to a certain
degree he actually had an impact people
weren't not addressing some of the
things that he was saying or doing
adequately enough right but now why the
[ __ ] would i do that i would never have
him on because then you're just like
giving him clout and you're you're
offering him more legitimacy
okay that's a fair point it's like he's
he is in front of so many eyeballs
yeah well i was pretty disappointed when
i saw aidan ross with like 230 000
people
just um basically building him up as
this funny yeah he did
and that's the thing like a lot of
people get stuck on like the joke side
of it or he's like is he is he not
joking he's funny he's entertaining he's
crazy he is joking like he is definitely
amplifying
uh certain real opinions that he has
yeah but ultimately it doesn't matter
what the jokes are because like he he's
really that person yes for sure it's
[ __ ] frankly scary that
someone that [ __ ] up is out there and
people do you think
he is definitely a
i do think that he is definitely a
misogynist
that's like
the most friendly way you can [ __ ]
put it i i said it he's like a violent
[ __ ] woman-hating cultist freak dude
i mean he literally thinks women are
whatever okay i talked about this
[ __ ] so much recently
but what happened he got one of your
videos removed well not one of my videos
i was i was covering the debate and his
like uh his tater tots uh
[ __ ] swarmed it like they do
everything and there's a reason why like
you see every comment section about this
dude who doesn't even have like really
his own like media properties with the
exception of his instagram page i think
like why does he have so many dick
writers is a question that many people
have because he doesn't make content
he's just like appearing on people's
podcasts and [ __ ]
and um
the reason for that is because he has a
discord server with like 150 000 members
in it all of which are paying uh from
what i understand like
50 a month like with the affiliate link
oh 150 000 yeah so let's [ __ ] go
right now so not entirely certain if
like every single person in the discord
server is a paying member but i do know
that they have an affiliate link uh you
know like they have an affiliate sp uh
link that they use
to get 10 off of like the next you know
10 suckers that they sign on you know
however many okay it's a pyramid scheme
and uh in that discord server they like
will literally swarm any kind of
negative criticism like oh this guy is
like top g
uh this guy is talking [ __ ] yeah all
right we've seen it any time we post any
like highlight featuring him or whatever
the comment section is it's always so
funny too they're like why are you
saying this about him uh you're just
jealous of him he would beat your ass
he's a professional kickboxer he's so
much hotter than you i look like you
want to [ __ ] him dude yeah all of his
all those fanboys are like really funny
because they're like first of all this
is not the alpha thing to do it's beta
as [ __ ] to talk so lovingly about
another man yeah like fellas like work
on yourself dude exactly
oh these are these are a lot you're not
being a top g these are our last three
cobra tate highlights look at that like
whoa what funky go dude 18
likes
wait what were these videos love i want
to see that yeah but shout out to his
fans for hooking us up with a hundred
ninety thousand views eighteen percent
yeah i swarm that [ __ ] it's crazy i just
posted i just posted a tick tock as well
on it like describing the
the describing the thing if you want to
if you want to link if you want to click
on it and look at it it's like a one
minute tick tock that i posted about
like the mlm uh you want to see that but
also can you link me in this i want to
read some comments on that one girl
oh yeah we found out the rapper
girl
oops um it's on your tick tock right
yeah it's on my take talk oh i i just
wanted to see like if
the comments have pulled through yet
because no one is coming in
by the way so this is the one that has
190 000
um
views and
it has 18 like ratio
that's [ __ ] awesome you ready for
these comments
it's been months and ethan still
believes the [ __ ] kidnapping case
hey [ __ ] this dude literally says he
pays off the police there
he literally he's like the king of
self-reporting too it's like so funny
he's like talking about he literally
said he went to romania because like you
know people laws are blacks there yeah
he's like he said that
he didn't human traffic he got arrested
because a guy's girlfriend lied about
being held against her will by the tape
brother right he was not charged with
human trafficking you're talking about
the guy who brags about how he buys off
the police there
yeah there's there's a lot there that
like uh there's a lot there that needs
to be further investigated but like
you're not gonna be able to do that
because
look
interpol is notorious for
uh being incompetent right it's it's
very difficult to
if the if the
country that you are in
is not going to self-regulate it is very
difficult for like the international
police or the international community to
come after you unless you are kidnapping
or or uh holding someone in a coercive
manner that is a national from like
america
right yeah
um
so that's the only time really run into
trouble if you don't do that if you're
just like kidnapping romanian women in
the romanian government or the romanian
police don't really care too much about
it or if you're like juicing the mafia
and also the cops and whatnot they're
you're not going to get a lot of legal
scrutiny
um
and and that's why you know people like
the the tinder swindler for example it
took them it took the governments uh so
long to coordinate and like actually
figure out how to arrest them right he
was like scamming
so many women in the same exact way
and this is no different than that and
it's just uh
it just seems like this is another way
that this person is like you know
the american government
literally was like yo this guy's
kidnapping women and forced him into
webcam [ __ ]
listen to this ethan klein has countless
examples of being the biggest hypocrite
on the internet what's funny is that his
whole crew are such yesterday that they
never con
contradict him even if he's wrong [ __ ]
when did i [ __ ] force women into
webcam sex slavery
point that out and then i'll be a
hypocrite in this i mean it's just it's
just great because like he has presented
himself as like this profoundly
successful individual when in fact he
has like uh you know not exactly a great
kickboxing career yeah he tried and
failed doing like all the big brother
reality tv [ __ ] he's like associated
with like nigel farage and tommy
robinson and all these other like far
right uh uk folk
and he had to escape to romania because
he
again was detained and arrested under
the suspicion of of uh sexual assault oh
is that right yeah that's
according to him yeah well he said that
romania is like a safe haven he's like i
can just [ __ ] argue he's like people
here it's no it's all good he's he he
has said two different things one he
said well three different things one he
said because loose rape laws two because
like in the uk
he had like uh uh as you're talking just
go ahead and show yeah in the uk he had
like uh like a sexual assault uh charge
uh and an investigation which he said
the charges were dropped but he hasn't i
don't think he's been back to the uk
since and he lastly said he went to
romania for a fight and decided to just
stay there
those are the three things i've seen
he's about to get kneed pretty hard here
[Applause]
he is i think his whole thing was he was
born
in the u.s and moved to the uk as a kid
or something i forget the exact details
yeah he's like half american or
something yeah everybody in this comment
section needs to be flagged by that you
know his dad is uh emery tate i think
right he's a chess player right yeah
emery tate is uh is a american
international master of chess and he's
the first black chess grand master like
he was that's great that's cool man he
[ __ ] up as a parent
good in chess horrible parent
yeah you know what i mean chess guys are
not exactly you know you know they're
always known to be a little
richard hanny said it masterclass and
slander from ethan
never really watched him before oh
thanks but he does seem like a fairly
resp resentful specimen
[ __ ] what who are you [ __ ] uh okay
well this is never going to be
productive because uh the nazi card
twice
um
he's also interesting i mean he's very
xenophobic he has like a bunch of racist
clips too i think like the thing is he
just like rides the wave he was like
more openly
uh
alt-right adjacent back in the day when
that [ __ ] was popping off and now he's
like
he's just doing manosphere [ __ ] because
the manosphere [ __ ] is popping it's
awful it's a good way to make money yeah
it's it's super easy i mean they are
basically taking on the jordan peterson
grift and like making it i guess zoomer
facing and a little bit cooler looking
like because jordan peterson cries too
much and kind of looks frail
no you know what i mean by the way i
love this he got this guy goes ethan the
last time andrew made a video about you
you're on the edge of tears on your
podcast he made a video about me
obviously oh he did yo it's like a
weirdest it's like a 20-second video
edit you remember that dan yeah he
posted it ethan you don't even have a
bugatti where's your [ __ ] bubbly
water yeah where's your sparkling water
ethan i bet you can't drink sparkly
water which is funny like i think
sparkling water is like pretty i don't
know it's not like it's not like the
masculine it's not manly at all thank
you dude
drink from the tap [ __ ] yeah sparkling
water exactly
yeah a [ __ ] hoe [ __ ] is wrong with
you here is uh the two boys tate network
brilliance
uh from one
what the lack of chin is astounding in
this photo yeah both of them where did
all the chins go
from one unloved child to another
good luck with all of that
good luck with all that yo where's
where's the [ __ ] video he made about
me i want to show him
yeah it's on his main channel man
yeah so this is awesome so shout out to
all these guys who gave me a ton of
views bro i love that for you guys
um yeah how many should we make some
highlight love i just want to give a
shout out to all the tate fans we've
been getting those babies one second
yeah just let us know
on the amount of 180 000 views
18 like ratio
revenue is
uh
the revenue is 700 bucks 700 bucks eat
my
girl it's your girlfriend
700
closer to a bugatti ethan that's almost
one bugatti you can buy some bubble
water can't you eat them wait did
someone say that in here or was that him
no that was zach that was me
oh my god let's hear some more of that
yeah get some bubble water ethan
what do you think you're a [ __ ] tall
ethan get some bubble water that's
really good that's really [ __ ] good
holy [ __ ]
zach's actually really good with
impressions yeah he always surprises us
i think this is it
oh yeah andrew tate responds to him
drawing wait wait wait wait wait wait i
just had an epiphany tristan what god's
just spoke to me and he made me again
not yet again and he made me realize
that wait no he he uploaded
this isn't it no no it was like some
corny ass video edit
people and just because i'm sorry was it
tick tock because i was looking no he
posted on his main youtube channel i
think it's in our doc dan all right i'll
look for it just go to like andrew tate
you're younger and smarter and more
intelligent and richer and more
successful and everyone wants to be me
and no one wants to be here and it's
like so
i mean this is so insecure yeah the
problem is people just don't understand
like
people don't understand that that like
this is a very insecure man
overcompensating or
uh i don't know i don't know what he's
over compensating for probably a lot um
his dad didn't love him because they
themselves are also insecure so they
like they don't have any [ __ ] they
don't have any way of gauging that this
person is just like being like i'm macho
i'm alpha i drink bottled water well is
the definition of like uh
sparkling stunted maturity i mean the
guy is yeah i mean it's but you know
there's a it's a target rich environment
there's a hell of people that will look
to that and go that's fire i love this
guy he's so sick and he like you already
pointed out he is entertaining so yeah
no i won't take that away from him
um oh [ __ ] dude [ __ ] this is from tate
speech i i believe that's his channel
this is it and by the way
take speech i think that that's a funny
name for the channel you know like tate
speech hate speech this is the thumbnail
by the way you look like a dog
[ __ ] goofy face emoji
so here we go you all ready for this
wait wait show me show me show me the
paid speech give me the tate speech
hey y'all come look at this
[Music]
wait but like you're making fun of
yourself i don't understand yeah these
are photos i took of myself and uploaded
to this do you think you found these
like
yes he does
these are all photos i posted
the curb music might get us
oh good point yeah isn't that literally
the the reaction like you're you're
you're joking like wait what's wrong
with this one yeah that one is not even
look at this [ __ ] loser with his wife
look at this happy loser in his house
you're a cop you're a [ __ ] ethan lame
you don't even drink i bet you
i bet you drink spot you don't drink
sparkling water that's what that photo
says you know add bubbles to your own
water ethan this [ __ ] he cooks
um
yeah i think like i mean look a lot of
that oh wait this is the best part oh
wait he goes look at this loser bro he
doesn't even have a bugatti
[Music]
booyah
yes
legend
wait he just made a fan cam of himself
and
that's fire
that guy is sick
he's like look at you and then look at
me bro by the way i have i mean i had a
rolls royce at the time which was kind
of funny because the whole rich thing is
like
it's just you could say but i mean i
probably you know i mean people get so
mad at me for the same reasons like the
same people that love andrew tate like
the tater tots yeah
they get so mad at me for being a
hypocrite because i have a nice house
and a nice car but then they're like
andrew tate is the king because he has a
nice house and a nice car
right yeah okay what else uh i didn't
even make it uh forcing women into sex
trafficking you're not the best part
about it yeah exactly you and you
probably paid taxes
probably didn't pay off police no didn't
have to do any of that so i guess i'm a
beta
okay but enough about the uh
but yeah apparently wait is this true is
this next item uh on the docket true
speaking of lifestyle influencers
uh i don't know oh
this one this that i'm highlighting
what's going on there upcoming guests
potentially oh this
is well liver king is in the works
because you know he he
he burned us so bad he big time does
because we try to get him on here yeah
when he was first popping off yeah
before yeah we're old school fans dude
like people he wasn't even on the radar
we were like yo have you seen this guy
liver guy yeah we put him on we put you
on liver and he big-timed us and then i
saw him on impulsive and i was like yo
man [ __ ] this [ __ ] yeah he just like he
he upgraded he was like nah we're going
on
you know
but uh we're working on nailing down a
date apparently he's on tour right now i
was like on tour doing what is he doing
like picking up picking up weights in
different
areas he's like he's doing press in a
bunch of different cities but for what i
i don't know
we're talking to his his main dude right
now and we're uh we're getting into work
i mean he's he's like a supplement sales
guy right like that's what it is it's
like the lifestyle branding that he is
like created for himself and he's like
attaching supplement sales to it the
thing is i'm i'm kind of curious about
him because it seems like when we
discovered him before he was like big
supplement liver king guy he was already
rich
and you kind of have to be rich to just
exercise all day and do nothing else
right yeah
yeah i don't wonder i don't know where i
don't know where he made as well it'd be
pretty funny it was like a cpa
it was just like you just bomb it like
accounting
you know what i'm thinking of doing
if we can work it out my idea for
something amazing is to get him to do a
blood test when he's here to test his
cholesterol don't leak it bro he's not
gonna [ __ ] do that oh oh for this
cholesterol yeah yeah no i don't wanna i
don't wanna test him for like steroids
yeah though he might be yeah he'd
probably oh interesting he'd be worried
about it i didn't even wanna check for
that but i don't even think about that
you can't even prick him dude his skin
is [ __ ] steel yeah it's like the hulk
liver king here you know yeah he's he's
uh he's primal primals
um maybe i'll can you tell if someone
has steroids based on like a hair sample
or some [ __ ]
because we could probably snatch a hair
i don't know bro i don't know i don't
work with you
can we piss test the liver king well
maybe well well maybe we could get him
to take a piss and save the water yeah
that'd be awesome yeah probably super
i'll drink it
so i can be his jack
have you seen the clip of all like i
don't know if it's real or not but all
the cows he's eaten and it's just a
bunch of cow skulls behind him on his
farm oh my god
yeah that's pretty wild no i i think
that like i don't i don't believe all
that i'm gonna be honest i don't think
so even though i do a friend who is like
really into liver now like he does eat
liver because i am um well he started
off as a meme but i think like he
literally is into it now like he just
and i've had the the raw liver like i
had raw liver that he made for me he
made it like a poke bowl basically yeah
it's pretty good okay really and i don't
like liver at all uh like liver is like
very uh
it is like a very distinctive taste
to it that i don't like
but um i don't know he he whipped it up
real nice but the question is not is
liver good because a lot of people like
liver the question is should you be
eating liver three times a day yeah i
don't think so i think everything in
moderation is what you got to do i feel
like
i just don't think so
yeah what's up but anyway let's see we
got um
first let's do a steve bannon fit check
here
oh what do we think about all this let
me take a close look at it at least wait
does he have the seven layers still yeah
wait oh he's still doing it all right
let's take a look here
okay pretty baller bro bye bye this look
amy am leon amy leon door pants
he's got 900. four callers man yeah hba
hba windbreaker
okay one thousand two hundred dollars
okay yeah
he's got a christian dior blazer on arms
are extra long okay
he wants the lightest
you gotta get that you gotta get the
extra long arms for that to hide the
boils and the pants that's true banana
republic yeah um he is like a like a
human skin tag bro it is wild says he's
got 99 problems with multiple shirts and
pens or not any of them and that's true
yeah my man is danced up he's looking
sexy
he's looking good he's nice with it he
actually doesn't look as bad as i
thought he would to be honest yeah he's
because you know he's cleansing from
the trump era hmm
so let's talk about some some new [ __ ]
actually we should probably our
advertisement because we're 40 minutes
into the episode already all right can i
pee while this happens yeah yeah yeah
i'll be back in between it though
thank you to stamps.com
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah when you're running a
small business every second counts you
can't afford to waste a single moment so
why are you still taking time out of
your day to go the post office when you
could be using stamps.com instead
stamps.com makes mailing and shipping
quick easy and cost effective in fact
you know we always talk about dan's
beloved girlfriend ally who uses
stamps.com that's right and it's just
such a great service because
you set it up at your home desk or
office or whatever
and you
use the scale they gave you you weigh
the package or envelope or whatever you
print out the postage
and that's it right and you put in the
mailbox you put it on your front door if
it's a box they'll come pick it up it's
convenient and less expensive for more
than 20 years stamps.com has been
indispensable for over 1 million
businesses stamp saw comes giving you
access to the post office and ups
shipping services right from your
computer
and get discounts you can't find
anywhere else like 30 off usps rates and
86 off ups
streamline your shipping process with
stamps.com easy to use software all you
need is your regular computer and
printer no special supplies or equipment
you're up and running in minutes
printing official postage for any letter
any package anywhere you want to send
plus stamps.com seamlessly works with
shopify amazon etsy ebay and more
so whether you're in office sending
invoices or an etsy shop sending your
products or a warehouse shipping out
orders samps.com is your mailing and
shipping solution so stop wasting time
start saving money
when use stamps.com to mail and ship
sign up with promo code leftovers
for a special offer that includes a four
week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale there's no long-term
commitment or contracts just go to
stamps.com click the microphone at the
top of the page and enter the code
leftovers thank you
and god bless stamps
welcome back
good timing
yeah so there's a few things that came
up uh since you were gone one
is the overturning of row
one thing that just happened recently no
we talked about that actually one thing
that happened recently was um
because you know reading the writing on
the wall the supreme court and
even
uh alito said in his opinion that they
want to look at gay marriage next that
it was an overreach this is clarisse
thomas
clarence yeah clarence
and i mean you have people like ted cruz
who are now openly saying on you know
fox news that uh uh making gay marriage
legal federally was a overreach and a
mistake and i for me it's just so
embarrassing uh for our country and for
the republican party in general i know
that they love this [ __ ]
that they have uh someone like ted cruz
and a supreme court justice saying that
human rights was an overreach since when
is human right ensuring human rights and
overreach
of the federal government they wouldn't
say that about [ __ ]
freeing slaves might they might say that
about [ __ ] uh yeah you know
racial marriage they did and they did
and they will continue to do so my
favorite counter argument to this came
from glenn greenwald who is a gay man
himself and uh
he he basically did the guys this is
something that like everyone is already
on board with why would you have to
codify it don't be ridiculous as if like
bro what do we not have object
permanence like you think we don't
[ __ ] know what the supreme court did
like a month ago what do you mean like
when they said the same thing about
abortion
yeah exactly
even the even the supreme court justices
who voted to overrule it when they were
when they were you know
and and senate testifying were like no
no bro yeah it's the super president
it's a super president then boom it's
not a super president anymore [ __ ] so
obviously this is the right thing to do
what is wild to me is that it was it was
like praise in the media is like
bipartisan compromise was found in the
house it's like 47 i believe republicans
voted yay on like
codifying or rather repealing the
defense of marriage act right which was
a bipartisan bill by the way back in the
bill clinton era in 1996 for those of
you who don't know that was where
bipartisan compromise was found to say
marriage is between a man and a woman so
repealing that
uh was was uh was bipartisan as well it
was so exciting is how the media covered
it 157 republicans voted no yeah that's
what i was just so passed 2022. it
passed the house
267 to 157 all 157 no's were republicans
only 47 republicans voted yes now while
i am impressed in a weird way and a sad
[ __ ] up way that 47 republicans voted
yes the fact that
157 people
elected officials in this country in
this year
were like nah [ __ ] gay people
oh well there's another record there's
another one that just came uh it's on
the docket today it was on the uh
earlier today which is access to
contraceptives yeah
96 of the republican party voted no on
that almost every single republican in
the house of representatives voted no on
protecting access to contraceptives for
women
that's crazy how
[ __ ] insane is that bro
only eight republicans joined the
democrats in support to to protect the
right to purchase and use contraception
without government restriction but it's
kind of it's like the the whole their
whole end game doesn't make sense
because they're like no contraceptive
and no abortion
yeah the end game is baby incubation big
big one road at least [ __ ] it's like
it's like a lot of uh a lot of people
say like oh women love to baby trap like
famous people or whatever but this is
like quite literally the opposite of
that where it's like republicans want to
baby trap women it's like you have to
you have to be trapped you have to
carry a pregnancy to term and and you
know go through this like labor process
which is torturous if you don't want to
have it it's a clear even worse than
that you know
again this is just black pilling and you
can
yeah this is just the beginning of of
this like [ __ ]
theocratic takeover from the supreme
court
who are literally part of a secret
[ __ ] cabal called the federalist
society
it's not even a secret it's a public
yeah but ice but they've got like slack
they've got like what's up groups we're
like hey hey let's [ __ ]
let's get them boys no i i think they
very openly have stated that this is
their goal is to undermine uh the the
uh the the power like the the republican
party's
overarching goals have been very
clear-cut they run on it they campaign
on it right they're like we're gonna put
supreme courts it we're gonna be we're
gonna put
right-wing federalist society supreme
court justices in the supreme court
we're in a court pac and then they turn
around and project and say democrats are
court packing while they're the ones who
are doing it they say democrats have
activist judges where they literally
have an organization designed to do
activism in their you know in the
right-wing way so
um they they i think have long-term
goals that they are now achieving as we
are watching you know american society
crumble before our eyes and this is a
you know 30 40 year long project that
they were pretty open about yeah i just
don't understand their end game and that
it's like okay we're going to remove
abortion rights i mean that's first of
all going to really piss people off but
then the next case that the supreme
court took up
which is uh
where is that one dan
oh it's uh further down it's down near
the bottom okay unrelated to the subject
matter that we're discussing but i went
to a korean market the other day and got
these like bts cold brews
oh and it's terrible
hassan
what
we stand bts on no i stand bts too i'm
just surprised like hey negative about
baby yes damn bts wait take it back bro
what did he say he said that he said
their drink tastes like [ __ ] yo no i
didn't say it i just said this
i'm serious kill his mic
no no no you're done it's it's killed we
can't it's on play this music play music
guys i regret to uh say today
that some insensitive things were said
about bts army who we stand
unconditionally
i've tasted their coffee it's delicious
in fact ah
you've stunned enough
you don't understand the damage you just
did
[Music]
we we've drinking their bts coffee we
[ __ ] love all the flav is there
multiple flavors of it
we love them we love all we love all
however many flavors there are we love
them all
[Music]
i'm just like i'm sorry i said some
things that i holding up a newspaper
will all be masked yeah behind me
holding up a newspaper being like this
is the day today i'm hassan [ __ ]
i am being held against my will but the
things i'm saying are truthful
i stand bts i need you to make a
heartfelt apology i i did i'm so sorry
that the coffee did not taste like ash
you did
bts good music the cold brew
was really good
thank you thank you just say that right
guys it was great what a [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] dude are you trying to get this
show [ __ ] bro they'll they're going
to find out where our compound is and
they will infiltrate it yeah do you
understand the peril that we're in
because you're [ __ ] wisecrack about
their coffee stop you're smarter than
that so sorry i'm not
mad i had a weak moment i had a weak
moment i'm so sorry for the things i
said i hope i can take it back i'm so
sorry it's not too late [ __ ] your mom
how about that it's like butter butter
dude listen i don't know any of the
songs
stop what what are you doing i just
offer because that's all good
i don't even listen to the music
it's cut he's off i don't even listen to
the music and i still stand
unconditionally
all right all right he said he stands
unconditionally yeah
i guess give him a mic back bro i love
their music and their coffee
okay
that's what you say okay i'm sorry all
the products that they show are great
thank you bro
well well said
anyway crisis averted dude yeah
thank god yeah so
anyway
just just kind of stay on point a little
bit yeah so
they've made abortion illegal and then
there's states like in texas that are so
restrictive
like in texas you can do about anyone in
the state can do a bounty lawsuit and
it's actually i think they made it even
illegal you can go to jail as a doctor
for doing some of these
uh health treatments and you know to the
point where
i was listening to an episode of the
daily
and a woman was recounting her story
about how like
a couple months ago she went to get she
had a tragic miscarriage and there's a
procedure that women get
after they miscarry to scoop out the
leftover kind of tissue yeah the
abortion tissue because if it's left in
the body they can get like a really bad
infection yeah and also just passing it
naturally is extremely painful
and so she described the first time as
you know
it was it was emotionally traumatic but
the doctor was or the hospital was very
supportive and made the process
a lot easier to bear they even did
really sweet stuff like they gave her
like a bracelet with like a butterfly on
it that symbolized her the lost baby
so fast forward
like a year later she tragically has
another
miscarriage
this time she goes to the hospital
because she's she's hemorrhaging or
she's she's cramping she's bleeding
she's having huge
uh blood clots in the toilet they're
really freaking out she's excruciating
pain she goes to the same hospital
and they tell her we can't do anything
for you at this time we can't help you
we can't do anything come back
if you're filling up a diaper with blood
filling it up all the way with blood in
an hour and they say isn't that already
too late and they they says well you
have about 20 minutes to get here if
you're bleeding that much and they live
30 minutes away
she says we're here because i'm
excessively bleeding and we're scared
they says we can't do anything for you
so she goes home with her husband
and she's forced to
pass
the miscarriage tissue
over the next three days excruciating
life-altering pain and trauma of
bleeding untold amounts
and she thought she was going to die
and this all because the doctors because
the laws are so restrictive now in texas
the doctors are afraid to even perform
something as routine as a
miscarriage treatment because it's the
same treatment you would give someone
who took an abortion pill an abortion is
a medically induced miscarriage that's
there's there's that's the medication
for it it's like a
free it's like a the medical term for a
miscarriage is like a early abortion
[ __ ] yeah so
it is
remarkable
that uh this level of cruelty is now
permanent barbaric it's [ __ ]
unforgivable
i mean
the greatest
the greatest story of that uh uh the
greatest example of like their untold
cruelty
is the story of the ten-year-old girl in
ohio i don't know yeah they said it was
it or not and it's real the first thing
that republicans did after uh joe biden
mentioned it i haven't talked about it
okay so there was a ten-year-old girl in
ohio who was raped
uh trigger warning sorry i should have
mentioned that beforehand um and
by a family member right uh i don't know
if the i don't know the exact deals i
don't know if it's a family member or
not but uh so here's what happens 10
year old girl in ohio gets raped uh then
ohio immediately is banning abortions so
now she can't get this this medical
procedure done she has to go to idaho
joe biden talks about it republicans
once he talked about it instead of like
looking into it further immediately say
well this is questionable the ohio
attorney general says i don't believe
the story there's not enough evidence
for the story republicans immediately
start disparaging uh uh everyone who's
like mentioned this it's awesome
however
the the the predator
in the
in this situation is already apprehended
he
uh he was arrested he even uh uh offered
testimony right like he he basically
admitted to doing this right
so what ends up happening in the
circumstance well they found out that he
might be undocumented so immediately
they switched what happened they're like
yeah it did happen and it was
undocumented and thank god this
undocumented like rapist immigrant is
off the streets you know immigrants are
rapists whatever they immediately turn
it over instead of being like oh [ __ ] we
were wrong jim jordan like deleted one
of his like uh you know tweets about it
right jim jordan also loves when rapes
happen like literally when he was the
athletic director at ohio like shouts
out to the buckeyes jim jordan totally
looked the other way as one of his
wrestling coaches was like raping the
students there
he loves rapes okay he does so you know
called the story fake you're talking
about so much youtube journalists even
after the arrest of a suspect a suspect
youtuber tim poole calls the story of
ohio child rape a hoax pool says there's
no rape kit there's no criminal charges
that's the lie up until now oh hit this
as a conspiracy why didn't anyone know
this girl reported this i don't believe
it's a hoax what she's [ __ ] 10 years
old 10 years old what fascinates me
about this story is that are you saying
that in a country of 350 million people
that people don't get that 10 year olds
don't get raped and get pregnant like
what is the point of even trying to say
this is a hoax you all [ __ ] know this
is inevitable stuff like this is
inevitably going to happen yeah why are
you pretending like this is something
that could never happen it's gonna
happen but wait there's more no it will
but wait there's more so then they
immediately shift over the narrative to
like how you know immigrant rape and you
know how prolific it is or whatever even
though it's not statistically speaking
uh you know undocumented immigrants
cause less crime per capita than
natural-born u.s citizens do there are
cares who rape but the girl needs
treatment exactly exactly
story matters like i'm just like going
through every single process here every
single individual step here it didn't
stop there though the the idaho
attorney general
came out
or was it indiana did he go to india uh
i think it's illinois
no no not illinois to get it done um i
think it might have been the indiana oh
god all these eye states uh i i think it
was indiana but okay the indiana
attorney general there you go came out
the indiana attorney general she didn't
go to idaho she went to indiana sorry uh
the attorney general came out and also
promoted the narrative of like the
immigrant rape and whatnot and then
said that they are going to prosecute or
look to prosecute the doctor who
performed the abortion
currently in the state of indiana until
july 25th my birthday uh abortion is
still
protected like you can still get a first
trimester abortion they uh have a
emergency legislature meeting to discuss
what they're gonna do for uh in the
future with abortion uh laws right they
haven't criminalized it yet they're
going to
but as it stands it's not that's why
this girl was able to go to indiana to
get this abortion this medical procedure
the indiana attorney general is claiming
that uh the the
10 year old or the doctor who performed
abortion on the 10 year old victim
is
is actually doing this illegally and
that they're looking into her
fantastic yeah and now she's actually
suing the indiana attorney general for
defamation good
look at this pasty-faced [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] who's a bro 10 year old rape
this dude wants a 10 year old to carry
her rape child to term yeah look at of
course you do bro
of course you do you know what if and if
the if that was your daughter you'd be
like hell nah if it was you you'd be
like hell nah [ __ ] demon dude you're
going to hell
okay
[ __ ] you
you're going to hell bro
yeah
um it's it's wild like every part of
this is wild and it just shows like
house a ten-year-old child to carry a
baby to term uh i don't know lawmakers
from
lawmakers in most red states republican
lawmakers in most red states that's why
i'm black filled man cause this [ __ ]
hog of a person
this demon he came out and said we have
this abortion activist acting as a
doctor with a history of failing to
report rikita said we are gathering
evidence as we speak and we're going to
fight this to the end he called her an
abortion activist pretending to be a
doctor yeah is she a doctor yeah she's
obgyn
[Laughter]
uh and here we have a a demon pretending
to be a human
dude i just like i don't know i don't
know where this is going to go i don't
know where like where we're headed is is
truly truly truly truly uh
way [ __ ] scarier than than ever
before like in the past we had trap laws
a lot of red tape that like made it
functionally impossible to get an
abortion in a red state like really
really difficult you have family crisis
centers like family planning centers
that uh portray themselves as like
abortion facilities with the express
purpose of like stopping you from
getting an abortion they're suspiciously
planted right next to an adoption agency
it's like basically like baby mills
pretty much like a puppy mill but for
human babies yeah um
and and now they've moved beyond that
and are decrim are criminalizing this
like criminalizing the procedure and
yeah like to the point where hospitals
in texas won't even perform
abortion treatments routine [ __ ] because
the hospital is afraid that some idiot
somewhere in the state or
is going to sue them because they did an
abortion even though it was just a
miscarriage or the doctor could even be
criminally charged by psycho demon like
this [ __ ] cruelty is the purpose in
this circumstance like that is the end
they own women's bodies they they that
is the entire women's bodies
but dude i mean it's just evil to force
a ten-year-old to get to to go term i
mean it's like laughably comic book evil
uh here's tim poole by the way this
[ __ ]
hack
i mean yeah 50 state landslide victory
for donald trump the little girl would
not have been able to get the services
she needed because there's no way she
could handle this pregnancy
it's sad that the life of the baby
will be terminated but
probably was con probably would be
considered to be not viable anyway
now look how is that sad [ __ ]
what do you mean
like he's literally saying a 10 year old
should undergo
labor that is literally harmful to the
10 year old like yeah
you can't give birth you dumb [ __ ] yeah
that's gonna
and the fetus is not viable either most
likely what the [ __ ] is he saying oh
it's so sad it's so sad it's like you
don't believe him he cares he doesn't
believe he's a girl he's just saying
that because that's what the appropriate
he thinks that's the appropriate thing
to say in the circumstances totally
pandering no one [ __ ] believes that
dude no one no one believes that you
have to be a real [ __ ] religious
psychotic zealot freak to legitimately
feel like every [ __ ] life begins at
conception and that like every
fertilized egg is a real life look you
know what believing life begins at
conception is a valid philosophical
stance to have
because frankly it's somewhat of a
philosophical discussion does it begin
yes here does it begin at conception
that's fine yeah well what is not fine
is not minding your own [ __ ] business
and if you don't want to have an
abortion at conception because you think
life started that's fine but why the
[ __ ] is your christian zealot zealous
zealot [ __ ] cult this [ __ ] ass
telling my jewish ass who believes who
abortion is a fundamental right of our
religion
right to decide if you want to be a
parent or not if your situation is is
appropriate to be a good parent now in
judaism they believe that life begins at
first breath bro i think that's a little
bit far i don't personally believe with
that but anyway the the point is it's my
[ __ ] it's my it's their body it's my
religion your religion
does not trump right remember [ __ ]
fascist [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] demon
but but ethan remember america is a
judeo-christian country right no
oh yeah no they cut the they cut the
judeo out of that so quick they were
like just kidding
where's she yeah
yeah that's why you know that and
according to torah life begins at the
first breath which is why whenever i see
like reactionary jews i'm like what are
you doing bro this is not an allegiance
that you will survive okay they will cut
you out so quick ben they're coming for
you yeah your walls ben yeah he just
thinks like he i don't know why he
thinks he's gonna be he's going to
survive that's the money yeah
they're they're definitely coming for
you benny bro i'm inside your walls ben
oh god anyway and i think daily mail
hits on it there's no guarantee should
have gotten the services but hold on
there a minute
why didn't the left
report the rape
why didn't the left
left in ohio
to dog what abortion services planned
parenthood they did why didn't they say
we want a medical exception for this why
does he think that wait pause me for a
second please why does he think that
like the proper legal channels were not
alerted in the circumstance like why
didn't you read the [ __ ] article you
thumb [ __ ] it's much better he's just
making [ __ ] up like oh he thinks like oh
nothing happened here no they did they
actually did they literally went to the
[ __ ] authorities
the authorities were informed dude the
child was allegedly six weeks and three
days pregnant therefore ineligible by
three days uh uh
if you don't think so
that's insanity that is complete [ __ ]
insanity dude
um a pressing public policy issue that
they would have won on for the record
can i just can i correct the record here
uh from what tim is saying uh no the
girl's mother had reported the rape to
the franklin county child services
agency which referred a complaint to
columbus police on june 22 so no the
police were informed you [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] what the [ __ ] the also what is
the left in the situation there's no
writer left in the circumstance it's
like
is he implying that the first the mother
of the ten-year-old or the ten-year-old
is elected he yes he is the [ __ ] bro he
there's either there's two people in pro
tim do you want 10 year old 10 year old
rape victims to carry their babies to
term yes his answer is yes yes or no no
he's saying that on the ground sad it's
sad that like uh she wasn't it's sad
that they ended this life i just want i
just think everyone
who's anti-abortion should answer that
because they always and another argument
i always see is like why you always
bringing up fringe cases bro that like
almost never happens it's like
but it does and your laws don't make
exceptions for it yeah but but even
even if it didn't like it
the the argument doesn't even like start
at the fringe cases like the argument
shouldn't even stay at the fringe cases
because the argument revolves around
autonomy okay the argument revolves
around
uh cutting off access and criminalizing
a medical procedure that
everyone with the capability of carrying
a pregnancy to term should have access
to it's ridiculous you can't [ __ ] run
around and be like i have a religious
objection to someone who's diabetic
getting insulin i think it's a gruesome
process don't interrupt what god
intended if you're diabetic you need to
[ __ ] die you can't say that about
diet diabetes that's all fatties but you
can [ __ ] say that about abortion and
it's psychotic it's completely insane
you're right though what constitutes a
sentience of what means what is a life
is a philosophical debate
but everything's a philosophical debate
and you can't legislate off of whatever
your distorted world view is where you
think like a fertilized egg is
legitimately a life um you don't [ __ ]
you don't you don't mourn uh in vitro
fertilize the eggs that don't actually
turn into a viable fetus you don't mourn
those lives that's millions of them uh
that that are you know thrown into
[ __ ] medical waste bins every [ __ ]
year we're gonna have to take a look at
them
that's crazy and they're they'll
probably stop the in vitro fertilization
[ __ ] too like because you know it
doesn't matter it's just fun they're
they're i actually heard uh a report
driving home the other day on the radio
about exactly that that a lot of those
clinics
are
worried and they're like desperately
trying to get verification that they're
not going to be prosecuted for throwing
out you know
it is wild every unviable in vitro
process needs to be carried the term
yeah right
yeah yeah as the laws
you have to come inside of your
respective hearts
you literally it's illegal i will it
will come to your house it'll shoot you
in the back of your head if you [ __ ]
pull out of your girlfriend okay [ __ ]
up
absolutely unacceptable do not waste
that sweet
milk
humans just another i'll tell you what
tim pool's going to come lick it off you
bro if you dare waste that the thing
about tim pool is like it's easy for him
because like he is a turbo virgin well
he'll never get anyone
he is so it doesn't apply to him so
incredibly unfuckable absolutely
on all the time totally so this is never
going to be uh an issue for him he's
never going to have a partner you
shouldn't have a problem out of the
conversation it doesn't it doesn't apply
to him it is
and non-applicable the man's ridiculous
he you have to have sex to get someone
pregnant first of all
yeah that's a big it just it's it's
[ __ ] so crazy but yeah there's like
two things you go you go it's about
bodily autonomy and like obviously yes
that's true from our perspective
but even in the case of the christian
extremists who out do the outright like
why wouldn't you even make these
exceptions where it's obviously just
cruel and inhumane to force for example
to give birth to a
stillborn moral consistency that's why
you can't even terminate ectopic
pregnancies because yeah or
because your worldview revolves around
you know christian medicalism like you
believe that you know god intended for
abortions to not well god intended for
you to get cancer and die so don't get
[ __ ] that's what i'm saying
thank you that's no but that's
unironically what i believe like
if you want to be an originalist all
right if you want to do a strict
interpretation of the constitution or if
you believe that like god is forcing you
to carry pregnancy as a term then if you
[ __ ] stub your toe and you got to cut
it off you got to get gangrene you got
to get gangrene and cut it off and
[ __ ] die okay you can no longer take
advantage of any medical facilities
going forward for the rest of your
[ __ ] life
temple if you get cancer treatment
you're a hypocrite bro
the reason it played out the way it did
the reason it was not reported is that
the left would have lost
i will say this what this one's not a
clear-cut hoax in the sense that someone
made up a fake story it's a hoax in the
manufacture of the story to a certain
dude it was gonna happen i just don't
understand this argument it's a road to
nowhere this is going to happen even if
you think it's fake aren't these q and
on don't they talk about like child
predators all the goddamn times you
think no 10 year olds are going to get
[ __ ] in that studio you know who's
raping kids john podesta not that
not her not her
john pedestal not no not the catholic
church yeah like here think about it
from the framework of like hillary
clinton's having a sex party with
children and then you know those
children oh yeah and then maybe you can
[ __ ] have some decency and humanity
for a brief moment in your [ __ ] life
anyway what an animal i i can't actually
i didn't know that temple was actually
this [ __ ] of uh i mean he goes again
he's another he's another wave rider you
know what i mean he's just like he just
follows deeper and deeper and he's
serving his audience they're just making
they're just making money man they're
like
there's no there's no intellectual
honesty no integrity no consistency
whatsoever
they're just making money they're gonna
serve you whatever the [ __ ] you need to
hear
uh they know where their bread is
buttered this is how they make a living
i had an idea a social experiment i
wanted to make a like a a youtube
channel brand new called like based
stakes or something oh dude where i do
like i somehow hide my face but just do
like all the regurgitating conservative
talking points and see if i could grow
it and make money and like become a
successful right wing i could do that i
fantasized about that i wanted to know i
had a youtube video i didn't do a video
that just came out on on my channel like
i i literally someone earlier in the day
asked me
hey
what do you think tucker carlson's gonna
say about aoc being arrested uh in front
of the supreme court
and i verbatim nailed tucker carlson's
model with the ghost hand verb yeah oh
you called that verbatim i was like
impressive yeah i called it like you
know five hours before he went on prime
time and said verbatim the exact same
things down to like calling aoc sandy
doing the
crazy
joker left
you know what i mean all the gimmicks
but don't you think that'd be an
interesting social experiment and then
after you build a fan base and [ __ ] you
come out like a hundred thousand sub you
say hey i'm a lib i just showed you how
[ __ ] easy this grift is i'm donating
it it doesn't matter all the uh proceeds
to prime parenthood yeah it doesn't
matter it would be funny but it wouldn't
matter it literally doesn't matter i i
am fascinated with conservative rhetoric
and i track it pretty
pretty closely i could be an infinitely
better conservative grifter so then then
be a leftist who's constantly getting
yelled at on the internet for like
innocuous [ __ ] that you would never yell
at other people over and yet people
still have the audacity to call me a
[ __ ] grifter where it's like this is
what i've been uh this is these are the
same things i've been pushing for over
the past [ __ ] 10 years very publicly
and it is wild to me how easy it is to
be a right-wing griffin man it'd be
awesome mr [ __ ] is one keeping helping
hunk of a man well if you were a
retarder then why would he say that
but anyway it's barbaric it's scary it's
[ __ ] nuts that our supreme court has
basically gone rogue
and then yeah the one case that's coming
up that scares me the most i was talking
about
by the way they have a 25
approval rating currently
so they just announced that they're
taking an extremely controversial
election law case this is a case from
north carolina where the state supreme
court threw out the state legislation's
uh drawing wait
the map
yeah so the map is the one that
i don't think this is the one i was
talking about dan
supreme court is taking on a
controversial election
here independence state carolina this is
it
uh the republicans
they're taking on a case known as
independent state legislature theory
which stems from the election clause and
article one of the constitution it says
the times places and manners of holding
elections for senators and
representatives shall be prescribed in
each state by the legislature thereof
it's a
radical
and insane reading of the i warned this
i warned about this like a couple weeks
back one of the last leftovers episodes
that we did if you recall i told you
that the republican project is uh built
around undermining uh all matter of like
federal control
and completely stop sidestepping
congress completely sidestepping senate
and the house of representatives
and basically beefing up uh the
executive authority to a certain degree
but most importantly utilizing state
legislatures where the republicans as a
consequence of gerrymandering and and
you know gaming the uh censure data or
or the sensory data or censure what
census sensory data oh my god my brain
is broken uh uh gaming senses data to
basically craft districts that are
beneficial for them so even if you're
like in the state of wisconsin for
example uh overwhelmingly democrat if
the state of wisconsin is voting uh for
a democratic majority
right there's still a super majority of
republicans in the state legislature
because of the way that those district
lines are district maps are drawn so now
you can use the state legislature to
overturn democratic results yeah in a
federal election what that means is you
can straight up say
yeah 65 percent of people voted for the
democratic party
doesn't matter we're declaring this
election null and void we're going to
continue saying that like the
republicans won so basically they want
to so the fact that they taking this
case
which is so radical and insane it's
never been heard before but it it's
telling me they're going to
say it's constitutional if they're
taking it like they're just [ __ ] like
in that way and if that happens then
this is gonna be far and away
uh
worse than anything the supreme court
has done
in recent times because it gives
basically in the 2024 presidential
election
any state legislator later which is
predominantly run by republicans can say
yeah you know what i see that biden won
well that's [ __ ] nice works we think
trump won and so yeah they they can also
just like appear it'll be chaos and i
just don't understand the end goal here
because this is just going to result in
like insane civil unrest and it's not
going to work out the way they think it
is there's just no [ __ ] way that
people are going to be like cool i guess
that's just how it works now they are
they're nuts they're they're drawing
maps they're drawing redistricting maps
in a way that favors the republican
party and they're doing it outside of
like uh the the proper protocols that's
the whole point of the north carolina
one but if extended to its like logical
conclusion you can undermine uh election
results in way more dramatic ways that
way because the state legislature will
then have full control over what to do
with districting and everything else in
any given moment that they want to
making their their dominance over the
over the entire state permanent
do you think just like they've done in
many other what do you think the supreme
court's going to say this is all good
i don't even know what the supreme court
will say in this circumstance because
why they take the case
i i mean they'd certainly i don't think
they took the case to say uh that you
know this is unprecedented otherwise
they would have said no
i i do think that they might go forward
with this i don't know how bold they're
gonna get but i also i mean
once they once they took down roe v wade
like you know
that was a test uh axios reported that
even the republicans were shocked at the
inaction from the democratic party they
literally thought that the democratic
party was going to put up a stronger
fight against them instead of just
kicking back and like waiting for people
to go and vote for them again in
elections is joe biden the worst
president ever or is he like because
right now i feel like he's actually just
the worst i mean i mean he's pretty bad
but he's also a victim of circumstance
you have like bro he's you have you have
i know but you have like 40 [ __ ]
years of like
the republican project it's like to pin
it all on joe biden i don't it's not
great but also
but he was in politics while this was
happening i mean so he should know
better but he's [ __ ] demented so he's
acting like none of this is happening he
doesn't even know where the [ __ ] he is
half the time he's not rising to the
occasion he's not rising at all he's
[ __ ] dead yeah he might be fighting
he might have been he might be in a
coffin you know who's gonna be worse
than joe biden though when joe biden
croaks from covid you know calmly
[ __ ] harris yeah he's gonna be dog
[ __ ] too she's a charisma sucker it's
your brain works we'll come out and be
like i'm gonna do a push-up competition
come on
dude push-up right now i don't even know
yeah i've seen clips of camela that kind
of give joe rum for their money and
their incoherence as well yeah
she always sounds like me when i [ __ ]
wrote like a fake essay and i pad the
word count
right like come on camera the whole
night and i didn't actually write my
essay
i think camel has got to be better than
sloppy joe at least her brain works yeah
but her brain works in the worst way
possible you know i mean her brain works
but not in a way where you know she's
going to do anything good i don't know
man joe biden is literally just a sack
of [ __ ] flesh
joe's safe as long as this guy yeah
remember maybe not of all time yeah like
but maybe recent right yeah out of
contemporary presidents george w bush
still the worst yeah george ronald
reagan uh donald trump hey hey hey what
guess what ronald reagan he is a [ __ ]
hero he's a g
he's like kind of the reason for all
this like
populist right-wing you know when you go
back and learn the hometown boy though
hollywood baby when you go back and
learn more about uh ronald reagan he
makes the conservatives of today
i mean same with richard nixon he's like
he's basically like a democrat by
today's standard yeah i mean he offered
amnesty you know what i mean think about
that that's like unheard of for for
republicans
it was like pro environmental protection
you know what i mean
yeah uh because
the overarching attitude in the country
at the time
was uh was was you know slanted towards
at least some level of progress the
obviously there was less progress at
that time than uh we have now with with
respect to civil liberties um
predating the latest supreme court
decisions of course but
but at the time that's what republicans
did reactionaries always react to
progress okay and if you don't have any
progress for them to react to if you
take your foot off the gas like the
democratic party has been doing since
the bill clinton era okay you're gonna
have republicans
do everything they can to pull back
the dial of progress as as aggressively
as they can and they're doing it they're
doing it successfully and they've had
these like incredibly complex and hard
to achieve long-term goals since the 80s
the federalist society is a project that
established in 1986.
so they've been added better at the game
than they've been added since 1986 and
there's no democratic alternative to
this there is no democratic party
alternative to this and the main reason
behind uh this reality this dark reality
is that the same masters own both
parties and that's it
that's
their because the democratic party can't
take action because they did if they did
actually take action if they actually
followed through on any of their
campaign promises that would be
inherently anti-capitalist or at the
very least against uh corporate profit
margins
and they can't do that
yeah i mean as long as 10 year old rape
victims are forced to give birth i'm
happy camper
let's move on uh just gotta get a couple
of title things oh that's true just one
last detail since you were just talking
about how reagan uh you know by is it
lid
my two day standards would be called a
lib or whatever yeah uh did you see this
whole thing from matt walsh uh yesterday
oh about the ozone the ozone layer for
the cover card matt walsh is probably
the worst human to ever live
because i was remembering the cfcs were
banned during reagan's administration
that's what i'm saying reagan helped the
ozone right but he goes remember when
they spent years telling us to panic
over the hole in the ozone layer and
then suddenly and magically just stop
talking about it and nobody ever
mentioned the ozone layer again are you
[ __ ] dumb bro remember when people
were just like getting [ __ ] polio
animals smallpox what happened dying no
one's talking about that anymore what's
up with that it's a conspiracy is he
making any accusation that global
warming is just overblown drama
yeah no obviously yeah when we were when
i was a kid the ozone
hole was a big deal there was a chemical
that people were using that was uh
tearing a hole in the ozone layer like
super [ __ ] fast it was [ __ ] up and
when they outlawed there was like an
international effort
uh to ban this chemical and guess what
the ozone layer repaired but matt walsh
is not happy with uh the results of that
in fact
dude
he'd be happy if the ozone layer was
still tearing open you just you just
like when you get
a wound then you should let it [ __ ]
infect why are you bandaging a wound
right why are you disinfecting a wound
many people were talking about germs and
how they they get into a wound an open
wound and all of a sudden you have to
cut the whole [ __ ] arm off cut the
limb off right but all of a sudden
somehow no one's talking about that
anymore you know maybe because it's
[ __ ] established science you dumb
[ __ ] and the problem with this well the
larger point that i always make is that
he can get away with saying stupid
[ __ ] [ __ ] like this and 41 000 people
like it
because they're just as [ __ ] stupid
like he doesn't have to make an argument
anymore he doesn't have to like uh he
doesn't have to deflect away from the
reality he can just deny it all together
you just say the world is flat
that's it and because he's on the same
team all these people are gonna be like
that's right brother
he's flat are you owning the libs is he
pissing off the liberals then i'm on
board more like anything that validates
their bias like aoc is a [ __ ] she's
got
she went to a migrant camp and pretended
to cry
it's insane to me by the way but now how
stupid this is the way he's missing that
ozone thing is kind of beautiful because
really the way that people work together
to resolve the ozone layer international
cooperation is what we need now to
address the climate change situation and
what he's denying uh didn't exist he
only can possibly perceive it as that
because of the excellent work everybody
did work together that he doesn't want
to see for global global climate change
here he is talking about uh climate
change discover the sinister phenomenon
known as
summer
so it's july excessive heat i'm not sure
what that means excessive i mean uh you
don't know what excessive heat means it
means it's [ __ ] hotter than usual you
dumb
[ __ ] it's like whoa fires happen oh
big word
oh liberals believe in wildfire seasons
extending as a consequence of more dry
brush oh the hottest day on record year
over year for 20 years uh summer
104 degrees in [ __ ] the uk
i'm sorry [ __ ] have you ever heard of
summer yeah love that for you no that's
like the dummy that's this that's such a
good amerifat like take where you're
just like nobody believe oh just [ __ ]
crank up the ac dumbass like bro these
houses are built for insulating heat
okay like trapping heat yeah because
it's hot there it's not hot it's not
that hot it never gets that hot they
don't have [ __ ] ac units okay and
also our solution to [ __ ]
global anthropogenic climate change is
not just crank up the [ __ ] ac and and
create more carbon pollution right and
exacerbate the problem it should be the
exact opposite
bro you've clearly not heard of summer
yeah dude what is yeah the
motherfucker's about to be like what is
climate change he's gonna do another
documentary who's he simply who was he
doing the summer bid for like like 100
oil executives no no like who benefits
from this other than like 100 oil
executives no and then and then like
seven billion people suffer bro they
already set the they already set the
stage oil and gas in the oil and gas
industry is known about anthropogenic
climate change since the 80s right or
even before that it predates that right
and instead of mitigating this disaster
they decided to hide it and they do it
in such nefarious ways like the whole
individual responsibility like drink
from a pla don't drink from a plastic
straw you know or or monitor your
[ __ ] intake uh and and monitor your
output like that's [ __ ]
this has to be dealt with with
regulatory mechanisms this has to be
dealt with at a systemic level okay
because every single person even if
every single person swapped their cars
right now to electric vehicles there are
still underlying systemic problems like
you still have a reliance on coal uh and
and gas uh natural gas in that
circumstance like sure you would be able
to
eliminate i think like one third of the
emissions which is gigantic right even
with cruise ships if you abolish cruise
ships right now
uh tomorrow you would be able to put a
fat dent
in our global emissions overall but
that's not the main source our main
sources are reliance on the fossil fuels
and and we cannot combat this by being
like oh yeah i'm just you know i'm
saving the turtles by not using a
plastic bag or whatever sure it makes
you feel good but that's literally
british petroleum and shell doing that
marketing to make you feel like you're
actually pushing for progress in that
circumstance and it whereas uh the real
progress is never going to happen
because it only has to happen at the
systemic level they've designed uh
propaganda so perfectly that there's you
know enough people that want this kind
of commentary back from [ __ ] like
matt walsh kind of flabbergasted because
it's like
i just don't understand how like wanting
clean air and water
is a lib is a lip tank it's like
you want clean air and water
like what the [ __ ] bro somehow you've
been [ __ ] convinced
uh
you're so contrarian and you've been
convinced somehow that you don't want
clean air and water that's
awesome first of all isn't that sort of
in the in the um the eye of the beholder
here isn't that kind of a subjective for
me except what what he literally
temperature known record the temperature
subjective you dude there's a [ __ ]
there's a human record we know
how is heat subjective it's a [ __ ] it's
literally measurable oh my god bro
there's literally a thermometer what is
what's wild in this circumstance is like
i can't get through there have been
748 heat-related deaths in spain
and portugal summer okay
so far and [ __ ] like that's
just subjective bro just literally don't
die like what's wrong i mean i i know
when i heard about this crazy there's
gonna be like tens of thousands [ __ ]
log cabin with like ac probably blasting
through the [ __ ] windows oh my god
yeah we looked up the stats only five
percent of people in your or is it
england have there is no aircraft
or less i'll tell you right now i was
there it's true there's [ __ ] no ac
holy [ __ ] yeah that do you know what
america
i sometimes i wonder what's so great
about america and then now i'm feeling
the ac blowing me now i understand yeah
no aircon
[ __ ] aircon lads we got to get
through this let's try to [ __ ]
let's try to get a sample of matt walsh
by the way this is matt walsh of the
daily wire
and who just welcomed jordan peterson
with open arms by the way who we love
jordan peterson who now straight up is
doing oil lobby propaganda
he just turned into like a hate preacher
i love this news
to be honest he always was he's just
like more unmasked now
airport runways are melting in the uk
matt walsh is like uh
better
get better runways [ __ ] isn't that kind
of a a subjective interpretation of heat
yeah no wildfires are
that's subjective
[Laughter]
isn't air quality somewhat subjective
what you might think is clean or what
you might think is dirty i think is fine
yeah
i don't know i don't know
all
right
i consider that excessive
but it's just it's a strange way of
phrasing it when you're talking about
weather
excessive like walking tornadoes or
weather bro hurricanes are weather
literally you could literally look at a
hurricane be like it's just rainfall and
lightning dawg just take the l like what
do you mean
excessive it's above the normal
there there's an average heat
it's a you [ __ ] ghoul you demon i
mean not not this matters but like his
[ __ ] uh like freak children are going
to suffer
uninhabitable okay
yeah
i just love that
yeah he doesn't care he doesn't it's
it's the same like it's the same crisis
of capitalism short-term gains always
trump long-term consequences we cannot
[ __ ] dial it back for a brief moment
and look to like 10 years in the future
and what our actions now are going to do
for our 10-year future or 20-year future
for the next generation we can't
comprehend that and when you're like an
89-year-old [ __ ] sitting in a
congressional seat i understand you're
going to die with a light breeze soon
anyway so you don't give a [ __ ] you're
just trying to you know keep getting
that oil industry profits or the oil
industry uh profits in the in the form
of [ __ ] corporate donations on
[ __ ]
uh uh public servants but like but it's
like matt was like you have children dog
you don't want them just it's ridiculous
and then there's also the other the
other side of this is like the worst
impacts of climate change are of course
always going to be felt by the
underdeveloped nations where
agricultural production is not going to
be able to withstand the erratic weather
conditions um because they do not have
the the infrastructure to deal with this
america is going to have and it has
already this has already happened
america has certain areas where they
cannot withstand this kind of uh extreme
weather conditions um and and that is
going to put a dent in agricultural
production that's going to cause mass
instability and this is not
i'm a [ __ ] idiot i'm a dumb himbo and
even i [ __ ] know this and i've been
talking about this for the past [ __ ]
10 years that this is gonna happen and
then now everybody
i don't know what's going on scientist
is talking about it every act of it it's
obvious
but
anyway let's watch this this is okay
come on come on weather this is
excessive
take it easy a little bit
well you are dumb the way that they're
framing the jokes
talking about the number of people who
are experiencing quote excessive heat
you know that's that's clever
and we should be back any second now it
might even be back now so uh hello our
streaming computer crashed
due to excessive heat
whatever that means yeah yes
extreme weather conditions whatever bro
everything should be fine now yeah
they're saying they're back okay thanks
everybody for hanging out sorry about
that that's actually never happened to
us before
in this new studio but
uh computer just straight up froze i'm
sure dan will figure it out he's a
wizard
but the good thing about youtube
streaming is that
it just picks right back up yeah i love
that so much anyway here's mount walsh
the genius back where we were the more
people you have in the world then the
more people who are going to experience
hot temperature so you could say
certainly
um billions more people
this year will experience hot
temperatures and is that wrong i mean
it's right yes
then experience hot temperature simple
population growth
that's obviously correct because there
are a lot more people
that's what it is
what's the problem it's just weather and
there's more people pop it's called
population growth sweaty incredible
brilliant they're not even trying
they're trying
he's not even trying he's literally just
saying there's more people so that's why
more people are suffering it's not a big
deal it's just that means there's more
people yeah okay jackass we're talking
about alleviating the suffering the
whole world is is is heating
the whole world
yes it's going to affect a lot of people
that's the point that's why we're
worried matt walsh
you've identified the problem it's why
no we're worried
it's it's getting to a point where i
mean you know what i really just feel
like that's an l if you die from heat
exhaustion that's an l law and that
means you're a [ __ ] lib [ __ ] and then
like people go all right yeah
brilliant take thank you listen matt if
i could control uh climate change and
just have it affect your house that'd be
awesome i wish i could do that but
unfortunately the world is an ecosystem
it does affect everybody so it's kind of
an interesting thing isn't it there's
temperatures in the first place there is
no karmic justice that's the whole point
like if there was these [ __ ]
would be suffering religious and what's
ironic is they're all going to hell for
sure yeah that is like if there is a
hell oh oh my friend you are dead
[ __ ] christians will tell you that
yeah jesus would be like
[ __ ]
bye bye
he hits he hits a butt like a trap door
button
see you mount walsh
no redemption for you [ __ ]
straight into a pit of lava bye-bye
um so i should say we are almost out of
time so if we want to hit on that other
topic we should probably leave let me
finish this
then we'll move on okay heat in the
summer all the same whether there are
seven billion people on earth or one
person on earth eat in the summer is not
shocking and uh
in fact it'd be sure his house could be
on fire it'd be like 130 degrees outside
it's just
it's summer guys i mean
there's the power's out his ac doesn't
work his house is on fire listen it's
it's summer guys
listen if everyone's color blind in the
world and you're the only one who can
see color or if the overwhelming
majority of people are colorblind and
you're the only one who can see color
how are you gonna [ __ ] describe the
truth to them you can't and
unfortunately with the way that we exist
currently with the way that the
republicans have gutted and democrats as
well have gutted public education in
this country there's no critical
thinking in this country unfortunately
there is no way they have created an a a
target rich environment of [ __ ]
idiotic baboons that will literally just
take everything that they're saying hook
line and sinker and and uh and and
repeat it and also demand it from their
from their uh talking heads that's where
we're at we're at it we're at a point
where unfortunately
yeah we're at a point unfortunately
where like people are too stupid
that like this kind of idiotic sentiment
this kind of anti-scientific thought
this kind of anti-truth
uh and uh deflection away from the
realities that we are experiencing
can
can reach a target market reach its
intended audience and they won't even
question it and they'll actually arm
themselves with these uh these these
statements
that are not based in reality and
continue to propagate this message
continue to repeat this message
it's it's devastating i don't know what
to do about it it just like breaks my
brain whenever i think about it
just to hit on whatever topics we have
left here
joe biden by the way he's experiencing
mild symptoms he's gonna be fine
medicine is great now especially if you
have like presidential access he's gonna
be totally fine but uh there is one
thing to worry about uh muhammad uh our
boy
wally
did make a prediction [ __ ] called it
straight up in
2020 that and this is a re-upload i
think it may have actually been posted
originally a couple of months prior so
it would have almost been exactly two
years well
if he does die you know and god forbid
long live the ki the king or whatever
queen
uh
uh uh we gotta maybe look into wally
please take a look listen to this
joe bison
joe bison
joe biden
this message from muhammad khan akin
professional son for you your body
you go check up on the doctor
you have to yield your life is to you
to you from now from today to
two years or one year and
six months or
two years new life
after this one you pass away
doctor
this message from muhammad khan akin for
president
you do do you good job for the usa for
the 50th day in two years
you do what's wrong with that
for us
you want to kudos
new country no more
iran no more iraq no more turkey no more
suri
for offensive kurdistan we'll give you
wait where's the very soon you go to
hell is that a difference oh that's a
different one he says that joe biden is
gonna dismantle iraq surya syria turkey
and and uh build like a like a massive
uh nation of kurdistan
uh that part is a little shaky yeah that
didn't happen we see we still have some
time left in the process
look alive jack we're dismantling our
nato alliance heads up turkey
yeah
we're dissolving your country if he had
created a unified kurdistan perhaps he
wouldn't be dying right now yeah yeah
that's true okay we have one topic left
to hit and that is jordan peterson who
we love so well being slept completely
swept up in moral panic there's so many
great things to go about this
jordan peter has become absolutely
pathologically obsessed
with trans people
we did a little bit of research last
night and it's really interesting
because medical hysteria
jordan
peterson said about conversion therapy
uh where's this clip oh yeah
he says about conversion therapy that it
shouldn't be outlawed because it's like
a small procedure that doesn't affect
that many people
yet he's obsessed
with
trans people getting a gender affirming
surgery now listen to the stats in 2009
a hundred thousand
uh lgbt adults have undergone conversion
therapy
350 000 of which are children you said a
hundred thousand it's seven hundred
thousand
seven hundred thousand
you're lgbt it's just small half of it
tiny miniscule hold on half of it
children now if you go to this [ __ ] that
he's obsessed with he says that's small
so it doesn't matter
there's been
7
928
transgender patients stud or well
wait okay i'm gonna hold it
get your stats uh mixed up here
how many people did the uh
i was looking for the amount of people
that did the surgery yes it's it's 9 000
per year which
you would uh it would take 77 years
to catch up uh there's nothing the
amount of gender affirming surgeries in
this country
per year that's basically zero uh in a
population 350 million right and uh
furthermore
a study came out nih what what was that
national institute of health in 2001
found that less 2021 2021 this year
found that less than one percent of
people who received gender affirming
surgery had regrets about it now this is
very [ __ ] interesting because this is
something they they told all the time is
that oh kids change their mind they
regret these surgeries
these aren't kids by the way these are
gender these are people who receive
gender affirming surgery so they're
they're not even kids they're consenting
adults this is 9 000 or 7 928 gender
patients studied
of that total 77 had some degree of
regret there is some degree of regret
for every single medical procedure
including plastic surgery hold on
and 33 had major regrets now there's
regret with everyone is it as low as
less than one percent because that is
staggeringly low um i'm i'm not familiar
with the numbers
so just just to throw that out there
just to just to
show you how hypocritical his obsession
and how pathological and just plain
weird it is
with trans people
here he is
crying about the tragic loss of budding
breasts
being
cut off this is a relatively decisional
regret is a relatively new area in
oncology research by the way like
medical ethics okay interesting so this
is something that they're looking into
now but of course like you know that
that isn't stopping uh anti-trans people
from uh you know transphobic people from
like
using this as an opportunity to just
like grossly lie less than one oh [ __ ]
there's a nuke coming
elderly missing what the [ __ ] that's
here
bro [ __ ] what do you want me to do run
outside right now
why is yours
leave
not stopping mine's stopped he says
silver silver alert missing endangered
elderly okay i scared the [ __ ] out of me
bro
go get him
what was it that i said there's a funny
i don't know if it's a tick-tock or
video but they're like when what they
think you're doing when you get an amber
alert everybody gets it just runs
outside oh yeah looks in the street
like there's partial mastectomy or like
uh you know
uh
like there's there's
there's regret in in every medical
procedure yeah listen to this all even
life-saving medical procedures listen to
this of cosmetic surgeries
research by medical accident group found
that 65 percent of people they pulled
had some level of regret jesus christ
that is significantly higher than gender
firming surgery less than one percent
jordan's probably as successful of a
surgery as you could possibly
it would be point four percent for
remember and i and i do stress this
point regularly as someone who takes dht
blockers for my hairline okay not
everyone's blessed like the hairline
king here
uh i know for a fact that
why did the camera pan to you there damn
what was going on when i was talking
about harold oh i'm not in control oh
i'm not we're talking about ethan i am
definitely not the hairline king yeah
anyway uh jordan peterson got hairline
uh gender affirming yeah
either a hair transplant or or
definitely taking medication forward
because his hairline repaired itself i
don't know how he exactly transplant by
the way matt walsh in uh hell he's
saying it's just hot it's just summer
yeah just a little shot it's always it's
always hot in hell matt walsh so get
ready for that all right
[Applause]
jordan peterson's new takes he just
comes out and does these monologues in a
suit like a batman villain
it's awesome
butchers and liars he calls this one
reprise it's you folks
particularly you in those three groups
psychologists physicians politicians
every
castrated child
every young woman made artificially
barren
every budding beauty
it's so exciting so ashamed of her
breasts
that she lets a machiavellian psychopath
cut them off now okay
this is not happening
no but also he's like it's like her
no he's so
bad bro if you if you like jordan
peterson still to this day you watch
that video you go man my man is spitting
clapping he's like not even cool at
least like cobra tate creates this like
air of being cool around him jordan
peterson is just like a sniveling little
cowardly old man who's like crying all
the [ __ ] time because consenting
adults are undergoing a medical
procedure that is literally demonstrably
successful and leads to better health
care results for the people that undergo
said medical surgery this is no
different than like [ __ ] crying that
plastic surgeons operate on third degree
burns you know what i mean how dare they
do reconstructive surgery after someone
well you know
burned their face off in a fire
unacceptable her beautiful
little budding breasts
yeah that's a crime i would love to take
a look at those budding breasts but i
never will every budding beauty every
budding beauty that's why people keep
clowning on him now because he's always
like how dare you like he'll say what
was it beautiful young little girls he
was like in pain ouchie the the elliot
page one he he had like a ridiculous
[ __ ] rant where he was just like
crying about being banned like oh so
memeable now cause he's just like an old
man he is so
[ __ ] pathetic it's incredible he used
to be this respectful respect
respectable guy
for a minute
benzodiazepine
this and this is a warning benzos are
very destructive yeah his entire
existence is like i mean first of all i
never respected him for the record i
always thought he was a piece of [ __ ] uh
i these underlying thoughts that he had
was guiding his rhetoric but he was way
more careful and way better at hiding
like resentment towards trans people and
[ __ ] where he would like
at least
make the effort to come across as like
neutral and he has completely dropped
that he's like i'm no longer neutral i
can't be keep those budding breasts on
your beautiful little body literally so
[ __ ] [ __ ] and send me the pictures
it's so insane but it's great i i
welcome this kind of rhetoric i have a
database
send me the pictures i'll save them
there he's such a [ __ ] clown like i
think a lot of this
a lot of commentary on the internet
revolves around charitability straight
up like i'll just admit it and same goes
for the left as well um you know it's
not about like how good your argument is
for the most part it's usually about
like how charitable people are to you
and understand what you're trying to say
and jordan peterson is losing all manner
of charitability by uh behaving this in
this like erratic capacity people still
love it like he's hysterical his his
elliot uh page rant had like three
million views and overwhelming likes
i mean yeah there's but it's a little
easy to make fun of now yeah
i think back in the day he would have
slapped way harder he's losing i think
he's losing grip
oh for sure on the barricades and keep
the degenerates away from the children
yeah but send me those pictures of those
budding breasts it's him he keeps the
degenerates away from the children those
beautiful budding beauties yeah that was
jordan peterson crying about the budding
breasts
here he is talking about conversion
therapy again she's pro conversion
therapy so he also hates gay people
pro-conversion therapy anti-gender
affirming therapy nine thousand
surgeries today yeah i can't tell i
can't tell what is a political
perspective is on the matter right um
the western world outlawing so-called
conversion therapy which was a pseudo
problem to begin with because it was
virtually never happening [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] did i just read
you owned yourself okay i mean if this
is a pseudo problem though
okay i'm an advocate for lobotomizing
jordan peterson it's only one person
yeah it's not a real issue jordan
clearly the benzo cold turkey rehab did
not work we need to lobotomize you
we need to carve out a piece of your
prefrontal cortex or you can do a liquid
lobotomization which is just a shot of
apple cider yeah that's true oh god
yeah my man is suited off that apple c
he's [ __ ] going crazy dude yeah
i just think you're such a [ __ ]
pathetic hypocrite this is a pseudo
problem and gender affirming surgery
that had 9 000
is a massive problem once again
yourself same with the matte wall [ __ ]
though doesn't matter literally doesn't
matter yeah it doesn't matter that it's
like uh he's he's hypocritical because
like people like what he's saying they
like yeah but it's it's so great
explicitly fundamentalist counselors who
are sporadically attempting to remediate
shut up idiot next
um so that part was good what rules you
sons of [ __ ] and then oh that was
what i was talking about yeah what roles
you sons of [ __ ] like dude you are so
bad
i think we missed that week up yours
it was a hot new take him talking to his
daughter about uh the pornography habits
of women dog his daughter's ex-boyfriend
is andrew [ __ ]
[Applause]
can i find the rap songs by the way on
the internet yeah yeah yeah dude yeah i
got to tell you because we just
discovered it recently please and i'm
pretty sure
we found a weak spot for him because
the most embarrassing one of all just
the other day he privated like he's like
trying to please please if you have them
please send them to me i would like
like the
worst i would love to listen so bad i
want to listen to some good music i
don't want to listen to music i want to
listen to her so uh listen to sexy
jordan pearson talking to his daughter
about her porn habits men look at
pornography and women read pornography
which is quite interesting yeah that is
that is interesting the google engineers
like great social scientists when
they're sort of let loose on the data
did a wonderful analysis in a book
called a billion wicked thoughts where
they looked at female pornographic
fantasies the google guys showed quite
clearly the pattern of female
pornographic fantasy preference and it
was basically
tough beauty and the beast by the way
number one watch category for women on
pornhub is
by far what i don't know lesbian lesbian
really yeah beauty and the beast women
are all furries what is wrong with
western degenerate have you ever heard
of cobra tate yeah he's the perfect
beauty and the beast archetype
he'll rape you but he's kind of soft as
well and we love that in our men he's
like gaston if gaston was the main
character beauty and the beast is an
archetypical phenomena they should have
made gaston the clear victor
in that section
raped that [ __ ]
dreamed of
absolutely
this is not our this is not our business
i mean jordan talks about how like
ladies love smut right like they love uh
you know uh pornography and like the
written form erotic novels and whatnot
and then he wrote an erotic novel about
his grandmother's [ __ ] on his [ __ ]
pivotal work
my maps of meaning
by the way
maps of meaning this [ __ ] should
have studied freud a little bit harder
holy [ __ ] dude interesting i was just
thinking about that the other day all
right let's continue oh pirate vampire
billionaire like hyper successful man
around you know arrogant kind of guy
they have a couple of interactions
there's a fair bit of rejection there's
some underlying sex how do you know so
much about romance novels tension he
realizes
she kind of entices him into
establishing a relationship with him and
tames her she's got herself her own
monster cool yeah lesbian videos because
they're [ __ ] so disgusting well i
even if it's like 100 accurate like
which i don't think it is but even if it
was 100 percent accurate like he's not
even saying anything okay so what by the
way and why are you telling your
daughter
just that's not a conversation what kind
of porn do you look at yeah she looked
like uh
dad women's favorite uh categories
lesbian number one i didn't this kind of
shocked me by the way japanese yeah
japanese porn is is i mean japanese porn
would be really good if it wasn't
[ __ ] one censored and two
women look so uncomfortable and so sad
in them i don't like jav but but women's
favorite and men's favorite is japanese
i just i never even thought everyone's a
[ __ ] weeb
both genders love milfs so that's good
to know unifying uh yeah unifying and
mature
and milk milfs adil
yeah so that was kind of interesting and
then the top women view more than any
other category man this one kind of kind
of surprised me scissoring ladies and
gentlemen
um part of the reason why this is
totally anecdotal there's no empirical
evidence to back my claim so i'm being
kind of like jordan peterson in the
circumstance but um
i talk to my girlfriends all the time
about stuff like this and one of the
reasons why i believe they or what they
tell me is the reason why they look for
lesbian porn is because like
usually in lesbian porn it's more real
like the orgasm is more real whereas in
like straight porn oftentimes the orgasm
is like exaggerated not real and women
can obviously see the see whether or not
the actor is legitimately stimulated or
not by the way shouts out to xander
corvin's that's my that's my dude love
how you see him here
and manuel ferrara actually also this
guy's a this guy's a favorite look at it
yeah no manual ferrara women love this
he's a legend love him uh great guy um
yeah i'm friends with him he's a twitch
standard what really yeah xander is is
awesome he's an incredible person he's
like a huge lefty too uh xander is great
johnny sins is actually quite popular in
tick tock i always say him i mean johnny
cena is like a meme and a legend yeah
yeah but but there you have it so so
someone tell jordan that women's
favorite is lesbian and scissoring
shout the [ __ ] out bro shout out to
women
women everywhere
think again sunshine i think yeah
there you go guys up yours woke morality
most viewed gay categories especially
straight guys
that's not surprising
uh
most searched gay porn cat uh kate okay
these are just actors
the the most gay category straight guys
is literally you're just describing my
audience right now
you're describing why i'm popular what
romance bro
yeah that's awesome that's us isn't it
this is mark of research for me
numbers yeah uh twink and femboy shout
out
and um
this is all very interesting stuff i'll
say and america number one is ebony
damn russia is all about the hentai huh
a whole country of hentai love bro yeah
i know that's brazil
big l big l for russia canada loves the
lesbians shout out
what's the western europe lesbian as
well uh well actually here it's all
about those this is milfs europe is
loving the milfs from germany and
eastward that's so interesting that
everyone wants mills women and men how
are united on one thing melves a dilf
not one man
not one mention of czech pickup porn uh
i don't like this it's this is a mention
of what check pick up porn oh yeah
public yes is that your channel that's
my [ __ ] that [ __ ] is pretty wild
that's what i like
okay y'all are laughing a little too
hard back there but what the [ __ ]
no those are good videos i agree okay
zach big fan i think [ __ ] your category
zach i think you found this laughter
right there
they just caught me i'm surprised
by the way i i've been watching this
show uh fuckboy ellen it's really good
the new season on hbo
and they were having these guys come out
and do confessions and one guy came out
and if they if they're like creepy or
give gross spoiler alert ethan
i'm just kidding go ahead
and anyway they go do you have a fetish
and the one guy goes yes i do
i love feet i have a massive foot fetish
and they're like dumb cause that's so
fast dude here's the thing like about
foot fetishes like why are you
self-reporting like people used to
[ __ ] throw that [ __ ] on the timeline
for free and now you just basically
cucked yourself now those puppies bring
the scrap in there yeah
i don't give a [ __ ] i still i still put
it on the timeline you know that
socialism is when free feet but like you
know uh people won't let the dogs bark
they won't let the puppies breathe
anymore because uh
all the foot fetishes couldn't help
themselves they just like literally oh
stop no shot play that it's only three
minutes dose of trouble i i gotta go
soon yeah
maybe
okay this is important
by the way real quick uh happy to tell
you guys that jerk off challenge
and try not to come challenge grew 255
percent this year
so weird there you have it doing numbers
baby he did some of the early
psychosurgery for epilepsy because in
intractable epilepsy sometimes the only
thing to do is radical surgery like a
corpus he cut the corpus callosum i have
so i have no idea what this video is
about i just when i was looking for the
thing of him talking to his daughter
this thumbnail popped up and i thought
it was funny
when you brought up
you had to pull it up used a little
electrode to map out the surface of the
brain and he mapped out the motor strip
which is just behind the prefrontal
cortex the old school jordan
is so boring roundabout it doesn't
actually get to the [ __ ] meat of the
argument ever
wait here most replay let's just skip to
this this is the
on the sensory jesus
it's right beside the representation of
the genitalia and so there's crosstalk
and so some of you are pretty into foot
massages and that's why
you know so it's i thought it was
i consequences know exactly you know
maybe maybe
the brain had organized itself so
particularly sensitive surfaces hey
guess what you know this isn't something
that's scientific
[ __ ]
i mean he is
yes the genital area is next to the foot
the only thing he's not a quag on is
when he's talking about his
grandmother's [ __ ]
so weird
up yours woke morales i will look at
feet if i want to
i love young budding beauties
all right guys okay oh well here in
society here actually is um
jordan peterson's uh ultimate fantasy
jordan and his dog i want to be caressed
gently by this beast
hard to look at on the outside but the
interior is soft as butter i did not
come on my dog i want i want this beast
to caress me gently
with his calloused hands
jordan i did not [ __ ] my dog oh my god
jordan what do you think about this dog
i did not put my dick anywhere near my
dog oh my god jordan i've never done
anything weird with my dogs
dude yeah he hard to believe he did he
did it he [ __ ] his dog definitely
[ __ ] i never have her way okay all
right
all right on that note man the
barricades
yeah
all right thanks for watching guys we'll
see you tomorrow after dark
uh welcome back uh hassan
left
shall not
be silenced
hell yeah brother oh people want to do
this where we pretend to talk to each
other like news anchors and then you cut
out the sound yeah i feel like so yeah
pretty good nice to have you back if you
didn't cut out
[Music]
you